all you jellyfish that red
this is your weapon whoa
whoa I am my weapon
this is my armor this is my shield oh I
will never yell not one time did I think
this deal will get blocked and I told
you maggots to stand in line and stand
next to me now this is the day that I
have promised you I told you if you
stand tall you won't receive the
promised land where we are here those
that ran in fear
I want you to look over and I want you
to see that brother right next to you
that sister right next to you that held
the line with you you had all the ups
and all the doubts but you did not Bend
break or phone you are made of Sterner
stuff the stuff that Legends are made of
we have individuals here that are frauds
those guys ran and we know who you are
they're trying to come back wait a
second
wait a second
I have a new phone
the FTC have folded
the CMA is on the Run
and the main protagonist has signed the
deal
yes we have them right where we want
them
beneath the Boop and we will not let up
we will continue to press we will push
this line so far down they throat they
won't choke the line for months and week
do not give in do not Bowl do not break
we understand now Phil Dominus Maximus
Spencer is the closer and he closed this
deal
you stood tall today's good day
now with all those badges that we gave
out weird I'm proud because you earned
them
I do not want to see anybody false
flagging out there but King they want to
celebrate if they were scared
but it was looking spooky can you can we
start day can we fold them not having
the confidence and did you given the the
community inspiring the community you
must reapply and you must have a made
man or made woman vouch for you
now go get your Xbox series X than us
and get right back in line Soldier and
if you don't have this you don't have
ish
wow what what what a day I mean General
I will say it was it was almost like a
Transformers moment you know light our
darkest hour things were not looking
good the CMA blocks the deal at the time
the red 4 reviews PlayStation showcase
imminent It Was Fear red rampant across
the Xbox station and we saved but you
you gave us the inspiration that we
clearly needed and now that fateful day
has come Jim Ryan has bet the knee
10-year deal according to Tom Warren has
been announced and uh here we are so
Paris let's start with you
this has been a serious turn of events
we've this thing has gone on for so long
what are your thoughts on all of this
that has transpired okay I have to start
here I am blessed
that I was here live I've been telling
you I've been telling you this card for
the longest I was like King I I got to
be there because he's going to be a damn
fool and you're a damn fool you are and
I love it I love it but I'm gonna be
real for a second let's go let's go
let's go I'm gonna take this back to LA
when they did the whole that's Fan Fest
and and all of that man and it was as I
was walking through the JW and I walked
by the infamous breakfast table and I
had it on up in the LA Live and to be in
that crowd and to see how like Aaron
Greenberg specifically just embraced
hold the line yes and that whole crap
everybody in there knew exactly what it
was and that's a testament to you and
the iron Lords and what you guys have
been doing from a Content standpoint of
you never wavered I mean you know being
real about this for a second you never
wavered you're like look Xbox has a plan
they're gonna figure this out and they
did they figured it out
they got Activision they got Activision
Blizzard they got their whole plan with
the mobile Call of Duty's not going
anywhere they're handing out 10-year
deals like like his candy the whole
thing is here's how I look at it because
I've seen a lot of feedback online
because I see this as a net positive
right versus trying to look at the
negative side of it where
I see people now saying but you're
consolidating the industry to Industry
is being Consolidated here's the truth
it's consolidating whether it's Xbox
doing it or not
we are seeing consolidation happen right
before our eyes so the question I would
push back to anybody on this is
if it's going to change if there's going
to be consolidation I would wanted to
see it be handled responsibly yeah and
at least what we're seeing on paper and
what's being said by by Xbox's
leadership is they're trying to do the
responsible thing they are trying to
bring these games to more platforms they
are trying to give us more value by
putting in their Subscription Service
things like that honestly that's all you
can ask now Phil Spencer came out and
was just like [__] like I've altered
the deal prey I don't alternate
exclusive yeah
that's not that's not good for the
industry right but the truth is some of
these games will wind up being exclusive
but other ones where it makes sense like
Call of Duty as an example is going to
stay multi-platform as it should you can
look on the PlayStation side with when
they acquired Bungie Destiny Marathon
all these games are going to stay
multi-platform so as a gamer to have
more choice on where I want to play
throwing cross play along with that as
well yes please
this isn't look it in a perfect world
we'd have multiple Publishers you'd have
all these independent Studios and there
would be that flexibility that's not the
truth of the matter it's just not the
reality of this industry right now so
for me and people can call me bias or
whatever I would rather see Xbox doing
what they're doing than to see a tencent
come in reached and take everything and
now they're getting it behind whatever
platform turn off all the lines and all
that so
got it I'm for this I'm I think this is
a good day that that this is happening
obviously
we can hope that you know there'll be
like a leadership Roundtable or
something they'll explain further
exactly what they're going to do with
some of these IPS where they're going to
live things like that but I think this
is a good day and King
I you got my knees
real name look let me let me say there's
one last thing let's go it was my honor
and pleasure to meet Cog an addict in
person we got to break bread we got to
hang out that was great in L.A all the
king y'all next yeah
we see you in Seattle but you're not
gonna see me at package
blame my wife yeah okay bro I hear you
bro sometimes you know concessions must
be made no doubt no doubt look I had to
make a choice either was going to be uh
LA or Seattle I never been to Seattle
and I just like to go when I go to these
conferences I like to work right and I
thought that
um E3 didn't have enough work for us and
I and I know Pax will always have that
grind that work that scene these
developers seeing these new games and
having those conversations so I had to
make a choice and the choice was
business over pleasure you know doubt no
doubt salute fact I appreciate you
brother oh man this is low we got the
legend he's limited time also the legend
Jazz recorded in the realm one of the
most nervous people coming into this
deal what are they what are they called
when you like abandon the Army he went
AWOL he went away with us he gave us
every reason to think we call that
treason what do you know he's got audio
problems he's got audio problems
every Xbox two audio issues
with those who abandon us in the midst
of battle who turned tail
you know what I was talking about I was
totally confident
we have the early process right now
charging you for going AWOL on the iron
Lord
how do you play in front of your king
with that I accept your apology
you know how Jazz truly accepts for his
apology he got to tell Rand right now to
turn his camera
but good try good try I just need to ask
for one thing since this public flogging
of you
this is like the Game of Thrones shame
and then we're flogging them down the
street
all I want to do be on the show with you
when you take that chip
because I did a live chip challenge and
I want to know if you were made of the
stuff that I'm made of
to look at our show when I took that
chip so I want to watch you as you
square them and wiggle sir yeah what are
we doing that Jess oh man uh I think we
got it for Xbox two ultimate this week
aren't we so it'll be
well I don't know we could we could make
an Xbox tool well we're gonna do Xbox to
Ultimate on patreon but the clip will be
posted publicly but it's not just you
it's Gaz and hargeet are doing it with
you right oh damn yeah
I would love that you can come on yeah
of course King yeah thank you yeah don't
forget attic you know I mean okay so
I'll make sure you know because you know
you're promised I mean I want Cognito as
well all right I'm good how you doing
to see this mass suicide
I need to see if people are made of the
stuff that I'm made of if you watch my
videos it's really good but look just
caught it again window centers on half
of the Xbox two when the best Xbox
podcast on the internet here we are here
we are you know we got the the the
announcement from Phil 10 years
asleep when it went down you know we we
got CMA up next
what how are you processing all of this
and how quickly things are moving
well
the team might still not go through it
if you don't get out of here
[Laughter]
maybe uh so don't celebrate oh don't pop
them there goes the jelly spine guys I
want you to see the spine
come on seriously though seriously
though yes
um
hopefully with this day with this
PlayStation I'm just gonna I'm I'm
bouncing it quickly about it tonight
because I got things I need to do
appreciate it but um I'm working right
now and I slept all day and it's like
it's throwing everything out of whack so
um my sleep cycle is just crazy right
now but um with this deal with
PlayStation hopefully people are
starting to realize that it was never
PlayStation who was I mean it was about
anchoring Xbox's future in the console
Market you know but this is a longer
fate this is a much forward-facing deal
and this was always about Apple and
Google's duopoly it was always about
mobile but Microsoft talks about mobile
they're completely serious about it and
like we we saw epic games have the
massive court case last year where they
did win some slight concessions but
almost they want almost nothing and it
was it was over this sort of Apple and
Google control how you can monetize on
their platforms Windows does not control
how you can monetize on Windows that's
why we have platforms like steam which
are great for the consumer on Apple's
platform you only have the app store
which is terrible for consumers well on
on Google on Google we only have Google
Play Store which is terrible for
developers and um you know and it holds
back Innovation on things like Cloud
Glam cloud gaming platforms which aren't
allowed to be monetized within-up
purchases on either platform
um with apple completely blocking it out
right but with this deal they get the
cloud to start chipping away that
duopoly and I bet your next year will
see another round of court cases with
apple and now with Microsoft on board
and saying like look we got Call of Duty
we've got Hearthstone we've got fallout
shelter we've got Minecraft we've got
all these Mega games and now we have the
kind of clout to really bring some more
consumer benefits the likes of which we
have on windows with steam epic game
store and all this competition it's a
apple and hopefully this deal will start
making people realize that it was never
about being a dick to PlayStation it was
never about foreclosing Sony like the
ftc's so desperately wanted to allege
without a shred of evidence the judge
laughed that out of court and you know
hopefully people start realizing this
but
um I mean without with all like you know
joking aside completely they say at the
end of it like the deal might they might
be closed maybe that's what I'm about to
ask you this CMA UK reporting on the
scene I need to know what you're feeling
as far as you know the CMA the next
steps well I think the CMA is going to
bend the knee they're gonna they're
gonna they're gonna fold it's it's
become political and they're being
attacked by MPS and saying what are you
doing we need this investment because
the UK is a sinking ship what are you
doing pissing off one of Mark's the
biggest corporations on Earth you know
so there's that aspect to it but I think
the CMA stuff will they've got they've
already got a plan in place for that I
think and it probably evolves everything
everywhere which is a telecoms provider
that used to be T-Mobile they're
rebranded in the UK for some reason to
EE it's it's I don't know I think it
might be separate from T-Mobile now I
don't know but they're part of BT which
on our infrastructure for telephony in
the UK so I think like um there's going
to be some kind of concession there but
um the court cases won't end and even
after deals closed right even after
deals closed even after the FTC appeal
goes away the court cases won't end
because Microsoft's now going to go
after Apple and Google I think I'm I'm
so sure of this they're going to go
after app and Google they're going to
make their own mobile app store which we
heard about which is going to have Xbox
integration and all that kind of stuff
and um it's going to be really exciting
like from it from Attack tacky nerd
industry kind of perspective it's going
to be really exciting to see where they
take it against Apple and Google because
I hate those confidence I hate those
companies so bad you guys know I know
Apple and Google killed my Windows phone
I was like vindictive about that [__]
but yeah it's really exciting and it's
really awesome and you know you guys you
know King what
podcast does you just have that in your
wardrobe what probably tell are you
talking about
are we talking about the crown am I yet
not the king
are you talking about my velvet robe oh
the gold belt
look this is your day this is your day
bro it's your day
a couple more questions there's a part
in Fable 3 where you become the king and
you have to make decisions on what you
did throughout the game and I could just
see King right now sitting on the throne
be like off with the head oh yeah he's
making decisions right now yes so the
victor goes to spoils
my name will forever be in the annals of
time I told you attic
you must take up the fight you know I
gotta I gotta ask both Jazz and Paris
this because they're here
it's it's what Dustin said earlier yes
let's go Paris I know you're what where
your answer is probably going to be but
I don't think Jazz has heard this
because he's just getting the sleepies
out of his eyes Dustin says take two is
going to be Xbox's next acquisition yep
he said his spider senses are tingling
yeah what do you think Jazz take two
pairs take two what do you think
well I'll just I'll just try them
quickly I mean Rand
did we not talk about this on Xbox 2 a
little while ago a few years ago where
I'd heard that take two was looking for
a buyer you did yeah and that would yeah
that is true wow we know Sony ain't got
that money
like
[Laughter]
put it on his own I'm done would you say
Jess you heard one thing what
one more thing before Pirates runs in
but I've also heard that Apple is
exploring building a video game console
yeah so if if you are if you were Apple
looking to get into and shake things up
who one thing you want to be doing is
buying a publisher right
this is
but I think that that would like you
know regulate this might be a little bit
like if if regulates though this was bad
apple buys only that might that might
well that you know would be crazy proper
you know I don't I don't think um they
would buy Sony proper I think they would
buy Sony PlayStation brand
you know it would be crazy though it
they took the PlayStation brand and they
kept all the people and it's like now
it's okay you know Sony we know you
can't realistically go bar for bar with
Microsoft but we got the money too that
would be a generous benefactor I've
heard that they're engineering their own
console I've never heard this for a
while they would be the only people I
feel like have the brand recognition and
because you think Xbox Fanboys and
Playstation Fanboys are better talk to
Apple Fanboys the thing the thing I I
hold out hope for is that they do make
their own console and they do we need
another one now leverage no we don't
because
um not from them if you didn't see that
the virtual reality machine is uh what
was that what what does it be like yeah
some some crazy
thirty five hundred dollars yeah so yeah
like how many people we had in the chat
um that's all give it one dollar y'all
could get one headset
that's what that is and to the fact that
if they do make a console it will be far
out priced because they believe that
their stuff is super pretty if you think
Sony has this arrogance look at the
iPhone look how much the iPhone cost
they would similarly price their console
like the the virtual reality headset it
will be so far it would never penetrate
you you know what they have to do two
King who's that dude that they always
blame he he goes everywhere and he ruins
the company then goes on and runs
another company
that's better let's see let's get
it feel over this let's get parishes
thoughts on what I just talk about as
well yeah mine real quick and I don't
know the chat was cooking me for my 240p
camera
funny Paris they're saying that your
resolution was still better than Final
Fantasy 16. wow messy
I do not want Xbox to require another
publisher again not to that degree not
to that degree yeah yeah yeah it's
starting to be way too much
consolidation at that point so if we get
to the point of a take two or a Sega
also joining I need my sake I'm okay
with Sega just not take two that gets a
little messy for me because I I feel
like Sega has very iconic names and
iconic IPS but I don't think they have
anything that like carries the wave as
like a take two and I agree on that I I
think the consolid the the compromise if
that were to happen even if it was Apple
since since we were just talking about
that those IPS got to stay
multi-platform I don't yeah we can all
of a sudden make Grand Theft Auto
exclusive to one system or something
like that or NBA 2K but it again goes to
the point uh someone like EA throw that
in there too or Ubisoft I think they're
too big a Publishers to want to see get
get Consolidated in that way I think
this Activision thing I like all right
that's enough let's slow up maybe you do
some one-off studios I can understand
that as you continue to grow out you
know their first party lineup but entire
Publishers I do think we still need some
competition some diversity out there
from a publishing standpoint in the
market to keep competition going so and
I do think that they know because of how
close this Activision deal went through
I don't think they would try another big
big but Paris I mean
just just at least
oh there we go just just just just at
least for two years don't you just want
a pure dominance factor
I mean I mean we did get Shaquille
O'Neal don't you want a pure shocking
like didn't you like it well no no not
for yourself
[Music]
do you like when young shag will just
get on the basketball court you didn't
know what Rim he was going to tear down
Microsoft to be so dominant in this
space that you quiver when they mention
new games Microsoft is having a showcase
oh my God I wanted to feel like Godzilla
has been cited I want you to run for the
hills I want you to hide and look from
under your bed
someone someone needs to draw an Xbox
theme Godzilla running towards a place
just imagine like the people being in
score Enix running
continue Paris no no this is this is
what I want being serious for a second I
want Matt booty to deliver on his
promises of a major release every
quarter um
but that's what I want okay do that over
the next two years well you know you
know Paris to to even eloquate uh uh
Matt to shoot a booty
um I believe that that guy's the right
guy I've always felt that and uh you
know you don't get a lot of his
publicity in the background because he's
doing the work in the background but
when the paperwork did come out and it
was noted that because of him Standing
Tall to keep those games coming to Game
Pass day and date I think he believes in
the products that he sees coming forward
and then he can deliver on that promise
so he would hold them to their fire to
those words that they did set forth so I
think he's the proper person for that
job and I think he would hold that line
for you you know that I agree with that
and it's so funny when uh him and Phil
were on the Giant Bomb couch yes right
and Phil got that twinkle in his eye
when they started talking about
um ID yes yeah they got some stuff
coming they for sure got some stuff
coming and even going out of that
showcase just getting that glimpse into
the future of okay we're starting to get
there and I think Phil even when we
interviewed him he had even said he can
see it they know what it's going to look
like over the next two to three years
they just got to start delivering it but
I don't think you need another
acquisition to do that
um internal Studios right now even
without activities never enough
let me get ready because that's what I
want it perfect transition and I love
because we getting opposing views on
what should happen next and I love this
is very important discussion so ran me
you have obviously talked about stuff
like this ABK is now where where we are
the you know we're at that we're getting
close to the Finish Line This thing is
almost wrapped up put a bow on it but to
your point and what Paris is saying and
and even Dustin was alluded to maybe
take two like what is your thoughts in
reference to to Xbox and the possible
continuation of acquiring more Studios
before standing patent well you know
they're not going to stand Pat because
the competition's not going to stand Pat
right tencent just acquired another
studio just this past week with Lucid
games right right they're always
dropping 20 or 40 like owning in
companies and Sony they've been making a
lot of Acquisitions as well so you know
and then you have other company I think
there was that uh that rumor it wasn't
really rumor it was reported that like
EA was almost acquired by Comcast
but who's to say EA isn't going to get
bought out by somebody else I mean they
did just sort of split up their
divisions right you have your the sports
side and your your uh other other uh
side which kind of like looks kind of
good if you're trying to maybe sell
yourself off
on Amazon possibly so the thing is
when I look at Xbox and it's like okay
we got 15 Xbox games too you know Xbox
game studios 15 Studios under Matt booty
you have Bethesda you have the Call of
Duty teams or what's coming from
Activision Blizzard
um the thing is it's like it's not
enough it's like you can never have too
much and what I mean by that is because
you have all the stuff but still 2022
was as light as you could possibly be
right right for content and with the
fact that video games are taking longer
and longer which matters it's no longer
it's no longer two years or three years
it's now four five and six for AAA games
right and sure you can kind of mitigate
some of that by maybe having you know
making two two games at a studio instead
of instead of one but then delays always
happen and delays can really screw up
your your um you know your fiscal year
22. go ahead and Paris go ahead yeah if
I could jump on on your point because I
I want to be crystal clear on what I
mean by this of course this is going to
be an arm race of course PlayStation is
going to have a counter of Court you
know on down the line there's there's
going to be a response to this happening
it's inevitable I think my my point
again going all the way back to the
consolidation thing is the more that one
or two Publishers basically controls the
entire Market That's not healthy for the
entire industry and my my personal
opinion I would rather see instead of
acquiring existing Publishers existing
Studios let's curate more new Studios
into your internal into whatever I think
before there was going to be I know that
takes time and I know that's not going
to happen overnight and clearly we've
seen through this FTC trial why
Microsoft has done what they've done
with Bethesda now Activision because
they needed immediate results think
about this year of Xbox game studios
without Bethesda it's pretty damn light
oh yeah so hey Paris yeah man you come
up with a proposal for Microsoft
because you're giving me an idea and I'm
gonna run with it right the king in
Paris contract this yeah listen listen
we open up uh Microsoft college right
and we get the best and the brightest
new students and developing games and we
can just post the match they come out
and we can put them new Studios right
there building from the ground up before
they even get anywhere we're not
purchasing any good Publishers we just
getting the best of the best all the new
ones come our way yeah